yeah so love is in the air you guys have
been lovers for how long
and this is her sixth six years eleven
wow
and when was the first time that you
guys if it's okay to talk about it when
was the first time you guys had sexual
intercourse um
probably two months no that's not true a
month into our release
but he had to drive i mean to long beach
every day
did you really yeah i went she she
didn't even come to my place for a month
did he uber
did he drive i drove to [ __ ] long
beach every day i'm asking
the woman uh he drove down there
he did and what would he do his filth
either
he didn't try to he didn't try he didn't
clean his car he had
piles of like bottles and just dirty
underwear everything oh
my god bro it's so gross but i was like
okay well i
i respect that this is his baseline and
he's not trying to front like he's
anybody else
oh that's pretty cool yeah so there was
no bait and switch huh
um there are a few but more of a
more of a maybe an effort thing not
really a cleanliness thing
from the get-go i knew he was a he was a
pig hi
you know hygiene wise he was a hygiene
risk they called it yeah yeah for sure
hepatitis risk
oh yeah yeah definitely wow
are you a sleeper away i had to get my
booster shot did you really yeah
oh definitely yeah he seemed like that
guy uh who's definitely got that fever
in him
you know he's got the potential for uh
he's got the potential for fever
liver fever oh if you look i couldn't
even imagine seeing one of his blood
cells under a microscope
who would even know it's probably just
sitting there [ __ ] vaping you know
um so you guys the f one month then you
guys got into sex now how did that kind
of start because i'm
or where was the first date let's
because i just want to learn about love
it's valentine's i want to learn about
y'all's love
we can talk about love what are you
did i feel like i'm on a yellow mirror
have you seen that show
bro bro yellow mirror
was very good and
i wouldn't give you i wouldn't give you
more of a laugh
if i wasn't so enraged right now sorry
man yeah yeah
but you're let me say something right
now dude okay that was [ __ ] funny as
[ __ ]
thank you all right but listen to me
okay yeah don't talk to me that way
i won't do that okay because i'm here as
well yes
we [ __ ] a month in okay and it was not
um we i go let me just stick the tip in
did he say that really well
hit training oh yeah circuit training
yeah oh yeah so we did a little we had
stations
and you guys went to an actual place you
just made it up and no in my apartment
in my apartment
um living room yeah we had stations
that's where you do the air guitar right
yeah yeah that's where
you know we do this and over here you
know you can put
just the tip in right oh wow i stuck it
in
and i stick it and stick it out you know
i stuck it in and stuck it out
yeah but she wouldn't let me stick to
keep it in there oh wow i like that yeah
yeah
that's all i did i did like five or six
of those very neat and literally
that's all we did oh wow the first time
so it wasn't real it was sex
you know on paper it was sex but it was
i just want to see if it was almost
like i want to see if it fit you know
what i mean like a meeting it was like
you're going into the gap you're trying
on
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
the second time was even a bigger
well the second time was a disaster why
because
i didn't realize our height differential
at that time
yeah and he was trying to you know we
were trying to do it
doggy style oh yeah and it turns out his
thighs are actually really short
oh yeah so um he tried it i thought i
was like a yam he's built like a yam
so he would have had to done a half
stand in order to get there
and his thighs apparently were burning
so midway through he was like i gotta go
home i gotta go home so he just left
and he just rushed home he didn't even
explain burning thighs is
very so the next the third time we did
it prison style which is straight flat
because it's the only thing that's all
the only style i can do
burn burning thighs hidden dragon that's
body sex
i can't do i've never done um doggy
the normal way oh wow because i'm so ch
like short my legs and stuff
so i just go lay on your stomach right
and then sometimes i have to like
squeeze their legs together like that oh
yeah yeah so i could you know tighten
the situation
yeah yeah do you know
was it do you remember being kind of
sensual had you guys been drinking or
was it no we don't drink i don't drink i
don't know i don't drink that's true
yeah yeah do you do but now had you been
drinking and you had maybe some tea or
something or what does she have to be
drugged out to [ __ ] me
or what is that what you're saying that
she has to be in some sort of state a
drunken state
for me or a coma or something for the
[ __ ] she's gonna let some guy
drive down a long beach in a [ __ ]
dirty car
i wouldn't be surprised if she has a
[ __ ] you know a couple of [ __ ]
mick ultras bruh for the [ __ ]
yeah but i also couldn't just say this
though theo is is that
um let's be clear about this is that
she's kind of
she's aware of who i am as well right
okay so you have that you have that
no she's not a huge fan but you know
it's not like i've done more than
youtube
right right very true basically i can
get above youtube
you know right it's not like you have to
[ __ ] uh who is that
um that girl gail um
did the um with the puppets you know i'm
talking about puppet gale
is that uh uh or no what was her name
she had a tv show went on the e
eventually
yeah get um you know what i'm talking
about one on the e entertainment or vh1
or something
oh grenda grinda no it was on
i i honestly don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about youtube what
was the ladies name blonde haired
gail ben um gilda gail bennett
hilda nighttime with um
and she she played with puppets grittin
uh
uh maybe not puppets makeup or something
tutorials
she did all of it sit down you know what
honestly just let it go no
yanny will come up with it i know you're
talking about it she's great
christine yeah right she has that her
she does her own
do-it-yourself show on netflix where she
makes cakes and then she talks to
puppets
i like that though okay that's cool no
this was gail i think or
grenda or gay girl uh hilda helga
herta blondie anyway can i just say
something
um you guys got it i love about you
right now dude is that you have some
new clothing because i've been analyzing
your clothing for the last year really
yeah and you look like you have some new
[ __ ] on like those pants i've never seen
you wear
what are those are those sweats yeah
somebody mailed these into us
and what brand cause i want to get a
pair of those i like how they thin out
in the bottom like that
are they nike or what no no no yeah yeah
yeah some guy makes these
okay i'll tell you we could just do it
afterward maybe well i'll just tell you
right now okay
while they're still looking for this
lady blonde hair girl no gareta um
hail big grace helbig she had puppets
yeah
endeavor endeavor it's called endeavor
they do have something i just get some
pants like that
you look nice though yeah green socks
that kind of goes along with the thing
yeah
thank you man so do you so you guys had
sex and after that then what happened
because then you would
was there love in the air already was
there a pretty strong love or were you
guys still kind of figuring it out do
you think
i'm just curious about love and like
okay
i'm going to be completely honest with
you oh wow somebody's getting mum yeah
you right now okay is that i met her on
tinder
yeah right and i was smashing
smack smashing gray wow smashing grabs
on our first date he was showing me
other tinder dates
yeah yeah wow it was like that uh show
uh supermarket sweep
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you smash smash and then all of a
sudden you
i found kala right i drive to long beach
the first time i see matt meet her at a
coffee shop
in my head i'm like oh [ __ ] but this
could be
a project wow no not a project but you
know that it's gonna be
i'm gonna know her for the rest of my
life or that guy oh wow that's pretty
it's a nice thing to say you knew there
was something different about her there
was something different about her you
know i liked her forehead
mm-hmm um i liked uh i could see that
pretty great
yeah i liked her the way she walked and
moved but here's the thing about pigeon
toad and she's a swimmer
she's hot right but what i hear is the
thing that
made me love her is because you know how
like mythological i am oh yeah and
pigeon toe that's part native of that's
yeah yeah native american but my body is
like you know um unclear
of what it is oh yeah dude you're like
my body can't decide
it's like an amoeba it's like an amiibo
right oh yeah you're [ __ ] like a
gristley rubik's cube yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah right
and i have eyes i look at myself in the
mirror yeah and i don't go
hey like fonzie right i just go you know
what i mean
but like and so when i was at that
coffee shop with her the first day
it was a long couch we're sitting on and
she was
really close to me and she just locked
eyes with me
and she was literally interested about
everything i was saying oh that would
scare me
yeah and she was hot too so i was like
oh this
what the [ __ ] you know i was hard yeah
oh my god yeah yeah my dick got hard
it's hard now oh that's good you can't
tell through the jeans
you can't tell yeah i couldn't imagine
telling at all
but i think that's cool i like to if i'm
hard i tell people in the room now
because i don't want to crime i'm not uh
i'm not doing it right right right
you'll be able to tell with those pants
you'll be able to oh yeah i'm not your
junk is that pretty clear too
i got that [ __ ] sleeping bird look
man you know yeah
yeah that's how my dick rolls down so
when i met her that's what happened
and then um and then here we are six
years later
you know well thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment i think
but of course i'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video
or on this video that's two different
options and you can also subscribe
to the channel check on our new video
subscribe to the channel
check subscribe check check subscribe